49 WHO ARE NOT PREGNANT,
DISABLED, OR MILITARY VETERANS
AND HAVE NO DEPENDENCE.
TONIGHT WE BEGIN A NEW SERIES ON
CHILDREN AND THE CULTURE.
OUR FOCUS THIS EVENING, THE
MOVEMENT TOWARDS PUTTING MORE
RISK IN KIDS' PLAYTIME TO MAKE
THEIR LIVES SAFER DOWN THE ROAD.
HERE IS CORRESPONDENT ELLISON
BARBER.
>> SOME CALL THIS A JUNK OR
WRIST PLAYGROUND.
OTHERS CALL IT AN ADVENTURE
PLAYGROUND.
THESE KIDS JUST CALL IT FUN.
>> WHAT DO YOU LIKE ABOUT COMING
HERE?
>> PLAYING.
>> THE JUNK PLAYGROUNDS ORIGINS
TRACED BACK TO DENMARK.
>> STARTED LOOKING AT, WHERE THE
CHILDREN PLAYING.
HE FOUND THAT WHEREVER THERE WAS
RUBBLE FROM THE WAR, THAT'S
WHERE CHILDREN WERE PLAYING.
>> THE IDEAS SPREAD THROUGHOUT
EUROPE.
TODAY THERE ARE RISK PLAYGROUNDS
IN GERMANY, BELGIUM, ENGLAND.
>> IT IS GOOD FOR THEM TO LEARN
THE CONSEQUENCES OF RISKS.
IT'S GOOD FOR THEM TO HAVE A GO
IN NEW THINGS.
>> THIS IS LONDON'S PLAYGROUND.
>> IT'S CHANGING ALL THE TIME.
KIDS GET TO DO THINGS THEY WANT
TO DO.
THERE IS A SIMILAR ONE IN
BERKELEY, CALIFORNIA.
>> WE HAVE EIGHT IN THE U.S.
>> SUPPORTERS SAY AGE IS NOT
ENOUGH.
>> THE MOST DANGEROUS THING YOU
CAN DO TO A CHILD IS RAISED THEM
WHERE THEY DON'T KNOW HOW TO
RISK ASSESS.
THAT HAS TO BE CULTIVATED.
THIS KIND OF ADVENTURE PLAY
REALLY CULTIVATES IT.
>> IS IT TOO DANGEROUS?
THE CDC SAYS EVERY YEAR U.S.
EMERGENCY ROOMS TREAT MORE THAN
200,000 CHILDREN UNDER THE AGE
OF 15 FOR PLAYGROUND RELATED
INJURIES.
>> I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
KIDS TO ENCOUNTER SOME RISK AND
AS THEY ARE DEVELOPING, TO LEARN
HOW TO MAKE GOOD DECISIONS AND
DEAL WITH CHALLENGES AND RISKS.
I THINK ONE OF THE ISSUES WITH
THIS TYPE OF PLAYGROUND IS THAT
THE ENVIRONMENT IS SUCH THAT IF
A CHILD DOES FALL, AND THEY
FOLLOW ALL THE TIME WHEN THEY
ARE OUT PLAYING.
THEY'RE GOING TO FALL.
THAT'S JUST PART OF GROWTH AND
DEVELOPMENT.
THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE MORE
SERIOUS INJURIES.
>> POTENTIAL BENEFITS ARE HARD
TO QUANTIFY BUT SUPPORTERS OF
THESE TYPES OF PLAYGROUNDS SAY
CHILDREN AREN'T JUST PLAYING.
THEY ARE LEARNING HOW TO BE
STRONGER INDIVIDUALS AND THAT
ARE ADULTS.
>> THEY ARE NOT GIVEN A CHANCE
TO BUILD THEIR CONFIDENCE, TO
FACE RISK AND REALIZE OH, I HAVE
THE COURAGE AND STRENGTH TO TAKE
THIS ON.
I KNOW HOW TO WORK WITH OTHERS.
I KNOW HOW TO PROBLEM SOLVE.
>> WE OVER PROTECT OUR KIDS BY
ALWAYS WATCHING THEM AND NOT
GIVING THEM THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRACTICE VALUES AND PRINCIPLES
WE INSTILL IN THEM.
>> IN COLORADO, A DENVER
NONPROFIT TESTED THE PLAYGROUNDS
NONPROFIT TESTED THE PLAYGROUND
PLAYGROUNDS.
A PERMANENT ONE CALLED FREE
RANGE PLAYGROUND IS SET TO OPEN
THIS SUMMER.